si louis blouin à fort mcmurray
on s'apprête à décoller on s'en va
survoler le site qui pourra accueillir
l'un des plus importants projets
d'exploitation de sables bitumineux dans
le nord de l'alberta
le projet frontières de teck resources
se situer environ 110 kilomètres au nord
de fort mcmurray
ce serait en fait la mine de sables
bitumineux la plus septentrionale de
l'alberta
[Musique]
m
le site n'est pas accessible par la
route
la seule façon de le voir c'est par la
voie des airs de projets frontières
s'étendrait sur 292 km carrés en pleine
forêt boréale le long de la rivière
athabasca
à titre de comparaison c'est la
superficie de la ville de mississauga ou
deux fois et demie la taille de la ville
de vancouver est plus grand que la ville
de laval
[Musique]
le projet entraînerait des impacts de
majeur sur l'environnement et la
biodiversité l'habitat de caribous
d'index de bison fait toucher 14 mille
hectares de milieux humides
disparaîtrait cette mine permettrait
d'extraire à terne 260000 baril par jour
et commencer ses activités en 2026 et sa
durée de vie prévue est de 41 ans
frontières entraînerait des émissions de
quatre mégatonnes par année c'est
l'équivalent de 900 mille voitures de
plus sur les routes annuels malgré les
effets négatifs sur l'environnement
une commission d'examen fédéral
provincial a conclu que le projet est
dans l'intérêt public en raison de ses
retombées économiques
c'est maintenant au gouvernement trudeau
de trancher d'ici la fin février une
décision épineuse qui mêle cible
climatique et intérêts économiques